and don't get too worried about what
other people think of you all the time
we must allow for creative failure when
it comes to generating ideas it is
inevitable that is because it is only on
our strengths that can give us the
energy to correct our weaknesses well I
think the simplest thing in dealing with
disagreements as get them onto the table
businesses are good at getting better
but poor at getting different he's an
Indian business tycoon investor and
philanthropist
he's informally known as a czar of the
Indian IT industry he has an estimated
net worth of sixteen point five billion
dollars
he's Azim Premji and here's my take on
his top ten year olds for success number
one is my personal favorite and I'm
curious to figure out which one you guys
like the best you're asking is so what
should really motivate you you know I
think that's a very personal question of
what should really motivate you I think
the longest sustaining thing which
should really motivate you is that
something in which you are trying to
quest for something to satisfy yourself
and feel good about yourself and decide
what that is and be constant to that
purpose and try to work for excellence
in that area and don't get too worried
about what other people think of you all
the time
we must allow for creative failure when
it comes to generating ideas it is
inevitable no one likes failure
particularly business leaders but
unfortunately all evidence suggests that
it is impossible to generate few good
ideas without a lot of bad ideas and bad
ideas are expensive but they have to be
tolerated as the physics Nobel Prize
winner faiman said I try to fail as fast
as I can that is the best way to move
forward on a new idea fail as fast as
you can failure should be forgiven and
forgotten as long as the lessons are
remembered and recycled you must begin
life and you must approach life with
your strengths absolutely essential
everyone in schooling very often keeps
on pushing one to focus on what is wrong
with us
or tells us what is wrong with us and
there is a very interesting imaginary
story of a rabbit and you must hear this
one the rabbit was enrolled in a rabbit
school and like all rabbits it could hop
very well but could not swim at the end
of the year the rabbit got high marks in
hopping but failed in swimming the
parents were concerned the relations
were concerned the friends were
concerned the elder friends particularly
they said forget about hopping you
anyway good at it you don't have to keep
practicing it concentrate on your
swimming they send the rabbit for
tuitions and coaching in swimming and
guess what happened the rabbit forgot
how to hop as for swimming have you ever
seen a rabbit swim while it is important
for us to know what we are not good at
we must cherish what is good enough it's
very fundamental to life that is because
it is only on our strengths that can
give us the energy to correct our
weaknesses to make changes in any
organization you have to have a measure
of very high persistency you've got to
go on and on and on and on we don't have
that persistency very often you fall out
just when success is around the corner
the customer is a great source for ideas
the customer can actually participate in
his getting better satisfaction provided
we can listen to the customer and what
he or she has to say and I think this is
the most important thing in terms of
customer visits in terms of customer
research is how do you get the customer
to say things or indicate things or give
nuances of things which are really
unsaid
and very often the customer himself or
herself does not know about it but that
is the source of truly very very
interesting ideas my friend was sharing
with me a story of his 8 year old niece
would always complain about the quality
of the breakfast and about the quality
of the food she would get in the house
she came from a family where there was a
cook and they tried just about
everything to please her finally my
friend took the child to a supermarket
and bought her one of these ready to
cook breakfast the child had to cut the
packet and pour water in the dish after
that it took two minutes in the
microwave to be ready the child found
the food to be absolutely delicious the
difference was that she had cooked it
with her own hat with her own hands she
had put work and effort into it I found
that nothing gives as much satisfaction
as earning our bones a rupee and is much
more valuable than five rupees found
well I think the simplest thing in
dealing with disagreements is get them
onto the table I think nothing nothing
breeds more discomfort at frustration
and anger with people if you bottle them
up that's very fundamental and you don't
always wind when you get them onto the
table but at least you come to certain
points of understanding which makes for
people to move forward and you know we
it to run large leadership positions
successfully you can debate issues you
can get issues onto a table but what you
would expect is that when a decision is
made people fall in line going forward
and if they have strong conviction
against the decision made it's best that
they get out of the system and don't
frustrate themselves and frustrate other
members of their colleagues with their
frustration as Gary Hamel puts it
businesses are good at getting better
but poor at getting different it is very
difficult for successful organizations
to develop disruptive innovations that
would threaten the basis of their
success often they are put out of
business when some similar company or
smaller company develops a radically new
technology which employs working in a
booming telecom company in the 1990s
would have suggested that free voiceover
Internet telephony would be something
that they could develop it took a
startup Skype to make a success of this
radical idea whenever you talk about
ethics and integrity in the Indian
context the two companies that come to
mind one is the Pattersons and the other
is Wipro what is so special about these
two companies that has been it has been
involved in these organizations how is
it done the very simple is done by
practice there is no other way you you
invite things aren't organized it is
practice integrity is practice
leadership is practice innovation is
practice it's all practice you've got to
figure out what you want your company to
be and what you consider is non
compromisable not negotiable
and they send those out and keep them as
simple as possible and keep them as few
as possible and practice them and
practice them every day every hour every
minute and have zero exception to them
what would be my advice to students who
want to start an organization like Wipro
yes sir you know the reality is you'll
have to start small like we started
small and you you must have you must
have a very clear understanding of why
you want to do it and what focus you
want to build and the focus you want to
build in terms of starting an
organization is something which must be
deeply passionate inside you because
you're going to go through ups and down
in many cases you're going to fail
certainly in parts of yoga your journey
you are going to have major failures so
unless you have a very clear commitment
to the focus which you build in terms of
what you want to build successfully and
have the flexibility to change that
focus because you have not judged the
market properly the markets don't run
after you in and you have to run after
what the market demand is or the market
demands you can create but you have to
be persistent and you have to be
prepared to make sacrifices because you
will have to make sacrifices in the
early stages and some very major
sacrifice and most of them will be
financial sacrifices because you won't
get cash flows the way you hope to get
cash unless you have a brilliant genius
idea
then you'll get cash
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because PR Envy asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want made a profile leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of the top
ten rules had the biggest impact on you
and why leave in the comments and I will
join in discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon